hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and it's John Humphrey over here we just
came back from Zack Snyder's Justice
League boy was half the crowd clapping
when that was done we're gonna do a non
spoiler review for you guys we're gonna
do our best to keep it short but we're
gonna do a spoiler review right after
this you know so that way cuz I know not
everyone's seen the movie yet but before
we do that we want to give a shout out
we really want to give a shout outs
today's video sponsor that would be
Stardust I'm sure you guys have heard us
talk about it by now already but
Stardust is this app that allows you to
do 30-second reactions for any film TV
show or trailer and I really like this
app a lot because I had this idea of
doing 30-second reviews like a lot of
people have after a while you get so
caught up in your opinion you don't want
to do that anymore but Stardust is like
the great most efficient place if you
just want to get the beats the
highlights of what someone thinks it's
really fun to use and then it's
specially good for like old movies or TV
shows something that's not super
up-to-date or relevant or something that
we normally don't cover the indie stuff
we could you stuff on start us for you
guys and a lot of you guys have been
following us on the app the community is
really growing over there we wanted to
feature some of your guys's reactions
from Stardust so here you go Justice
League yeah oh hey what's up it's me
Batman
I can't believe I've just seen a
live-action Justice League film short
version of the reactions overall I
really enjoyed it it was a lot of fun
the CGI is kind of man the villain was
really bad but overall it was so much
good she's yeah yes again let the film
down I was a little weak short version
go bad movie is a fun cartoon bad movie
well there you go mixed bag of opinions
so make sure to download the app and
follow us first at the real rejects link
in the description box link in the
pinned comments we do actively use this
app and we really do love using it
you're gonna hear us talk about it more
I'll get ready just today now wants who
are full Justice League review hey you
guys are still here
hey another real quick thing I want to
mention shout out to Ruben over there
who came up to us at the movie theater
we didn't really get a chance to talk he
was with his really hot girlfriend or
hot sister or whatever she looked his
age so I got to assume something not to
associate hot associate thanks to Ruben
seems like a really nice guy start we
couldn't chat more we were with friends
you don't know how to handle those
situations but shout-out to you buddy
I'm sure you've heard a lot of people
talk about this before you heard a lot
of opinions about this film in some ways
everyone's right about it yeah
everyone's correct about this film I've
personally found this film to be very
cheesy very corny
I believe that's what I've been saying
that this movie to be and I have never
said that in a negative way he's walked
away from this movie going yeah I'm
aware that maybe overall when you weigh
what's good and bad it probably moved
fall on the technically not-so-great
side however I gotta tell you guys like
I enjoyed it I really enjoyed the hell
out of this film every time they were on
stream maybe I'm just a sucker for like
cool comic book shots and seeing the
whole team assembled whatever every time
they were on screen especially when
they're suited up I'm like yeah I'm
enjoying it too I wish they had solo
films for yeah especially for Aquaman he
was the one where out of everyone I was
like he's the one who should have had
his solo film first the actors it's such
a good job with the characters with
their roles the chemistry was definitely
there there was nothing off at all with
the characters
we think that's off with this movie is
plot some pacing some editing and
everything but out of the actor yeah
everything is fine and the cast is good
let's park so you have problems with
well this sometimes feels off
consistently when they're just talking
with each other are trying to have
character scenes I've never really too
emotionally invested I never feel the
stakes even though they keep repeating
what the stakes are with the damn mother
boxes that's every movie it has no
emotional center so all the emotional
scenes feel very disjointed and some of
them work and some of them don't it
doesn't that's the point though is that
sometimes there's some really good
emotional scenes there's one scene with
cyborg and the flash where that was a
cool that was a cool scene there's even
some random scene with Lois Lane and
Martha Kent yeah where I was like there
are all sorts of like good little
nuggets that pop up here and there and I
think the the thing that could have used
the most of those was the thing that got
the least which was Steppenwolf because
Steppenwolf leaves no impression this
movie and is overshadowed by the boxes
yeah so by the end of it Steppenwolf
never feels very scary or threatening
and part of that has to do with just how
the movie treats the civilians to the
fodder but I don't even know why they
got that actor not really given much to
do and the CG on him just covers
everything up the CGI on him flatout
terrible so that's kind of a problem
with a lot of the scenes in here because
even outside of Steppenwolf there are
some scenes where the CGI just does not
look very good and it hampers some of
the action and it hampers you know some
yeah the the flow of the movie like
there's that fight they tease in the
trailer that takes place at that mascara
it was conflicting for me because I was
thinking to myself this is technically
all really cool stuff yeah I'm so used
to the Wonder Woman movie in that
mascara when it's clearly stuntwoman and
practical effects it was distracting
how much CG either was with the human
being yeah and that's one of the fights
I liked more in this movie like I
thought it was cool that we finally got
to see you know like full-on like
horseback battle sword yeah arrows and
all sorts of stuff the CG they used to
stitch it all together really does fit
make it feel disjointed especially
coming off Wonder Woman this is
the definition of DC taking all the
notes and going everyone said we're too
dark so we need a really lighten things
up take all these notes a hundred
percent yeah they went full opposite
spectrum so it's a much lighter tone
everyone's cracking jokes Batman cracks
jokes sometimes they'll and sometimes
you're like I don't know if that'll
really crack a joke right now but okay a
lot of this movie I kept going wait a
minute what keep doing your yeah there's
a lot you're gonna forgive the easiest
way to sum this movie up of why I feel
like I can forgive it is because I've
seen a lot of the DC animated movies and
I've seen a lot of the DC shows watching
this felt like I was watching an
animated movie or a DC live-action show
while this movie would work better in
those formats like if you literally took
this movie it just made it animated all
the problems that people are finding
including us will just be a million
times easier to forgive because simply
because it's an animated movie yeah it's
weird charming to me it's so cheesy and
it's such a cartoon the rules of the
world established in this movie are
sometimes not applicable there are no
rules hence there's a really big lack of
danger that's actually no salvan there's
no thrill too much of the app you know
like stakes at hand it's just a fun
comic book adventure and the thing is
it's coming out of time when you get
some great emotional and believable
comic-book movies and this goes back to
being like really cheesy and I'm not
just saying it I'm like this is pretty
much exactly what I've been saying I'm
thinking this film is gonna be and then
by the time it's done I'm like yeah
that's almost exactly what I wanted the
characters are good the plot is weak and
I kind of anticipated that like I would
I didn't really feel like it ever ever
be in danger it's everything I expected
the film to be a really nice surprise
and I will say for the spoilers is how
they handle Superman yeah how they
handle Superman one of the best things
this might be the best version of Henry
Cavill Superman yeah I feel like this
might be my favorite thing about that
movie I laughed there was some pretty
cool action moments there's a lot of
like
cool comic book shop yeah there's so
many times where they're lined up that
I'm like if you guys see Deadpool cuz we
can't pose that many times to do that
many superhero without it being like
guys please it's one of those flawed
movies that I can't help but just feel
entertained by cuz even though it's
filled with flaws the flaws would
entertain me and then when it's good
that would entertain me so I was
thoroughly entertained there was maybe
one or two moments where I was a little
bit bored and that's just like them
talking when they're not suited up one
of them has their pseudo I'm usually
fine this movie gains a lot of goodwill
in that it's not taking itself too
seriously anymore it takes some of the
notes in the way opposite direction but
I feel like every element of this movie
has points where it's not so good at
points where it's pretty good and yeah
that applies to everything
I almost feel the same way you do about
the whole movie but just a little less
because the excitement of seeing them
all together doesn't save as much for me
I do think that everybody on the cast
including cyborg more than I thought
yeah the one said he was like the weak
link Batman's kind of cool Wonder Woman
was good she did her thing but the
highlights to me were the flash and
cyborg more than Aquaman
I think Jason Momoa will probably kill
it in his solo Aquaman movie and I think
Jason Momoa delivers his lines great in
this film he surprised me felt like he
might be the least essential to the team
I was having trouble of figuring out who
what he added after a while beyond one
particular moment which you know and
even Batman in the second half of the
movie I was sort of like ah I feel like
there are some people on this team who
are way more essential to this fight the
scale of this fight than us is he's the
leader bringing them to to where to
fight but he's not even like really
leading during the fight you know he's
never playing leader role he's more like
I found it let's go any unites the team
then it seems like everyone's pretty
willing to do it it doesn't it doesn't
do the Avengers thing where at first
they do it all they can't get along like
things that kind of do a little bit but
for the most part everybody's on board I
was surprised that Barry and cyborg
ended up being my favorite character
cyborg because he felt the most like a
character and Barry because he was the
most fun - yeah yeah overall I was I was
just summing up by saying is exactly
what I've been saying in all the trailer
just an entertaining time whose cheesy
it was corny it was a live-action
cartoon while it's flawed the flaws were
amusing
it wasn't flawed in the way of like BBS
where I'm like this is dull it's not
making me mad
nothing really moved me and nothing
really thrilled me all that much like I
kept having the anticipation for like ah
things are finally gonna get cool and
maybe grab ya and they never quite did
but it's it pretty funny but it's a
pretty fun cartoon alright DC and Marvel
fans did you see Justice League what did
you think is better
age of ultron or justice question all
right well you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification bell beginning thought of
ten what about videos that make sure to
download and follow us on the stardust
app that is part of the reject community
now so make sure to follow us there our
page you come give us a hug